honoring the king and Beyond TNT Tuesday
post game show presented by KIA there
was a new all-time scoring leader in the
NBA after 38 years of Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar holding the crown and we
are joined by the King right on that
court at crypto.com Arena Shaq Candace
Jamal Crawford lefko here LeBron James
congratulations you are officially the
all-time scoring leader I have a quote
for you my friend throw me to the wolves
and I will return leading the pack you
are now leading the pack how is the view
um
it's so uh surreal because it's
something I never you know made a goal
of mine or set out to do is uh just
happened
um longevity me being able to be on the
floor for three multiple franchises
going and trying to be the greatest I
could be every single night and um
having great teammates and coaches that
allowed me to be me so
um I don't know if it's hit me it hit me
a little bit on the floor with my family
got on the floor after it happened and I
seen all my friends and family but
uh it hasn't quite soaked in just yet
LeBron's check here uh first of all
congratulations I can remember coming to
see you play when you were in high
school 18 years old and you know I I
know what type of person you are I know
what type of play you are but are you
saying to yourself now that I have the
record I know I can play at least two or
three more years
no I'm not a big fella for sure I know I
can play a couple more years you know um
you know the way I'm feeling the way my
body's been uh reacting to me throughout
this course of the Season you know I
know I could play a couple more years
it's just it's all about my mind you
know if my mind is still intuitive I'm
still motivated to go out and try to
compete for championships because I feel
like that's what I can still uh do for
it for any group of guys for any
franchise I can go out there and still
help win multiple championships or win a
championship so that's my mindset but
it's all about the mind if my mind is
sharp and I feel motivated to go out and
prepare myself every single day then
you're not gonna continue to play this
game
Brian first congratulations
um it's Candace we saw you rocking the
all black today we saw you come in uh
wearing the headband so we knew tonight
you were going for it at what point in
your career because you said this wasn't
a goal of yours at what point in your
career did you see the record and say
I'm gonna I'm gonna go for it I think I
can get it
um hey Candace first of all uh congrats
too on on the move to Vegas uh that's
super dope
for me um I never said I'm a go for it I
think once I saw the number get closer
and closer and I just you know been
available on the floor and I've been
able to still be productive over the
last couple years I was like wow oh I'm
2 000 points away I'm 3 000 points away
I'm four thousand points away now and I
feel great
um I said okay well it's possible you
know um you know when I read about the
history of the game I never thought that
this record would ever be touched you
know especially the way uh Kareem played
the game and how long he played the game
just didn't think nobody would have that
type of longevity to come out on the
floor and play at that level for so long
so
um it's just a complete honor to be a
part of this league be a part of some of
the greats that's ever played this game
and for me to be right there at the um
you know at the Apex with them
Brian what's up it's Jamal man just one
second
pissed off man knowing you from 16 years
old and seeing this journey and not just
tonight but seeing everything you've
done and you've always inspired all of
us you've always kept going you've
always been driven even to this point
are you a little surprised like man do
you ever just take a second to say my
work has spoke for itself and this is
what I do but man look where I'm at this
point in time right now are you still
surprising yourself man absolutely
um you know my wife and my boys asked me
you know do I ever surprise myself on
the floor still at this point in my
career and and I thought about it I was
like yeah sometimes then uh to be able
to play at this level you know 20 years
in and the minutes I've played the games
I've played either through the regular
season or through the postseason you
know to still be at the Apex in my game
um it's a it's a pretty surreal feeling
so you know hopefully I can continue it
but at the end of the day I'm just it's
just been a pleasure to be in this
league for for 20 years and however long
I you know able to go whatever the case
maybe I've had a hell of a ride LeBron
last question
I said at the beginning of the show I
wish that I would have had this moment a
chance to pass up Kareem you now pass up
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar I know what my
attitude would have been does this now
make you the greatest player of all time
are you allowed to go uh you know I'm
gonna let everybody else uh you know
decide who that is or just talk about it
but it's great it's a great Barber Shop
uh talk yeah I want to hear you say
that's a big problem listen big fella
before you said bro me personally
myself I'm gonna take myself against
anybody that's ever played this game
um you know but everyone's gonna have
their favorite everyone's gonna you know
decide who they who their favorite is
but
um I know what I've brought to the table
I know what I bring to the table every
single night and what I can what I can
do out on this floor so
um you know I always feel like I'm the
best to ever play this game but you know
there's so many other great ones and I'm
happy to just be a part of their uh part
of their Journey well LeBron James there
has never been a basketball player to
score more points than you
congratulations I appreciate it
you drinking tonight I know you're
drinking some Covina oh yeah we drinking
some good Vino tonight and we're gonna
have a little low both on tap too so uh
yeah we it's going up tonight for sure
now all right big fella love you baby
all right
[Applause]